Saudi Arabia's government is spending $80 billion to remodel Mecca
including $3.5 billion to build the largest hotel in the world
Why is Mecca having a dramatic makeover?
Mecca is the home of Islam's holiest site - the Kaaba, within the Grand Mosque
Around eight million Muslims made pilgrimage to the city in 2016
Visitors peak during the week of the Hajj
During the pilgrimage an extra two million people cram into the city
Making it the largest annual gathering in the world
Religious tourism is crucial to the Saudi economy
It's the Kingdom's third-highest source of income after oil and petrochemicals
But oil revenues are faltering and the budget deficit exploded
So the government is trying to boost tourism to help plug the gap
The goal: An extra 20 million annual visitors to Mecca by 2030
The Grand Mosque is already the largest in the world
In 2016, around $10 billion was budgeted for the work
By 2040, capacity will be doubled to nearly seven million worshippers at any one time
Pilgrims will be accommodated in the biggest hotel in the world
With 10,000 rooms
And 70 restaurants
As part of the redevelopment, 13 of Mecca's 15 old neighbourhoods have been razed and rebuilt
Of the city's scores of old shrines, only the Kaaba survives
Saudi authorities are banking on the redevelopment attracting more pilgrims, and more money, into the economy